kill monger I don't think so friends
hello guys hello I am Ken and I'm set
and this is the obelisk gaming PC from
omen by HP and Seb don't be fooled by
its relatively small size inside here is
a monster and it's the perfect machine
for our little test today
yes and today's experiment is all about
framerate arguably the most important
element in competitive gaming it's the
speed at which your gaming machine can
redraw the arena of battle in front of
you the speed that that information is
getting pumped into your eyes as you are
dropping enemies left right and center
and they're left in the dust just going
white why did I die
frame rate frame rates why you died that
is the idea anyway and that is exactly
what we are gonna put to the test today
so let's find out we're going to be
using the obelisk gaming desktop PC from
omen by HP to look at exactly what
framerate means for competitive gamers
does it really give you the edge in
battle and just what kind of frames per
second can we squeeze out of this PC
when we really put it through its paces
and if I said we have some good news
from our friends science studies
suggests that gamers have some of the
fastest - reaction times of any group
and in fact we can improve our reaction
times by playing games in particular
action games well with that in mind
let's take the obelisk gaming PC and
ourselves put them to the test and see
what kind of performance we can get ok
we are gonna be playing the first-person
battle royale shooter apex legends which
has just kicked off its second season
now it's free-to-play it's fast and it
demands quick reactions if you're gonna
become an apex champion now let's see
how we handle the beginning of the game
gimme guns please yes alternator ok
that's not a bad start so how we doing
on the old frames said ok well as you're
running around here we are looking at
about hitting between I'd say 160 and
200 frames per second Wow per game
obviously you just shot they're up to
250 but what we're seeing I guess as in
you and I through this wallet areas 144
right yes we are seeing a hundred and
forty-four frames per second ourselves
and there's a very good reason for that
we're using the omen by HP 25 inch
display and that is a 144 Hertz 1080p
monitor it's a gaming monitor basically
there's a difference between Hertz and
frame rates in Hertz that is how quickly
the monitor is able to redraw an image
every second and it tops out at 144 now
the PC is rendering the game at anywhere
between 150 so far and 2 or 300 frames
per second now as long as the PC is able
to render that game above 144 we are
going to see exactly 144 frames coming
at us we haven't seen Serb though as any
enemies no Shoji we seem to have dropped
into a fairly quiet area and what will
the interesting kam I think is when we
get into the action yeah frame rate is
gonna respond
okay so we're running at 1080p and
actually if you scroll down through all
the different settings oh yeah which is
leading is maxed we are mentally
everything is maxed so yeah we are
looking at some pretty good frame rates
oh yes we're gonna third party some
people here so let's see what happens
your eyes in the frame rate yep
I'm keeping an eye over broken already
alright we're at about 175 oh down to
those down 60 whoops oh come on cam you
can do better than that our Xterra
I'm gonna get greedy here and go for the
final kill Barry you've snuck up on him
yeah listen a limb Oh Oh team house the
frames they say it's we're over 200
currently I'm gonna just wipe this one
up here because he's got the L side or
not there's some there's some smoke how
does it handle the smoke yep we're still
over 150 there we go that's a full team
down well done T you're gonna go and
revive your friend or are you gonna go
and get the L stuff I'm gonna go and get
the L star me so apex legends is just
coming to its second season yes it is
introduced this new weapon which is at
the moment shredding everybody oh really
I mean it's good in in close range
especially there we go see my other
buddies got it those guys it's all the
way play it's frame rates and team play
it's all about getting hoovering up all
the gold things that's what I'm doing so
in that in that combat we actually had
the frame rate go up to about 200 on it
our way I think that might be to do with
the fact that we're in a bit of an
enclosed area now obviously in terms of
getting a good frame rate out of your
game the more the game has to render so
you know big areas of the map for
example they're more it can affect your
frames per second yeah but at least it's
good to know in those high action
moments you're not going to be losing
any extra frames no exactly so one of
the things that's really important about
apex legends is being able to hear the
enemy because yes they make some pretty
noisy footsteps and if you can perceive
where they are before they found you you
can always get the jump on them so cam
you're using the omen by HP mind frame
headset now I am and it's a 7.1 surround
how does it sound it sounds really good
I think it's so important I've played
apex before with just sound coming out
of a monitor and things like that and
it's so hard because you know you you
need to know where the enemies are or in
my case who's shooting me and where
where they're shooting me from so it's
less footsteps and more bullets yeah
it's it's more learning how to survive
with the with the genius of audio but
it's also great because then you know
there's a lot of sound going on in the
apex you've got the enemies as well but
you also get your teammates issuing
pings and you know to hit hints and tips
things like that boarding targets so you
need some clear audio yeah
got if you've got comms enabled as well
you'll have voice chat coming through as
well
now you currently don't have your team
with microphones on the other end
we've got your mic deal which means they
can hear you if you ever want to mute
that though you can just flick it up and
it's a it's you know up to me you can
down to speak where are they oh he's
already down but why not finish him off
you're gonna need a new gun anyway yeah
they're sore masked it right there did
you oh my goodness oh I'm gay I'm
killing myself in my own alt all right
sir there's only three squads left
exciting alright well now things are
cooled down a little bit why don't we
see what kind of frame rate we can get
out of this this PC when we drop the
settings to that lowest let's do that
let's hide in the corner mm-hmm
cowardice settings Karen smart disabled
everything off lowest settings all round
alright happy to fly woah enemies
oh he's lit he is so let okay you're
currently at about two hundred and you
were up at about two hundred fifty
frames per second there oh my goodness
I shot everywhere other than ability yes
oh my guys are zipping ahead and our
frame rates are zipping as well look at
that 230 yards so this is quite a big
area so it goes yeah
320 is just rendering the skybox I guess
Oh enemies there's only two squads left
Seb here we go okay all right so let's
see what the frame rate looks like when
you get a championship yeah this is what
I'm expecting now all right Oh alt Alton
oh okay so it's all happening with that
man would say jump down get involved and
the champion goes up to 300 frames per
second look at that not bad at all great
stuff happens if I unload all my bullets
hey loads of frames well there you go
sev picks champions maybe it was I'd
like to say it was all me but it may
well have been there the gear as well
that we're using you know looking at the
damage you did the middle you did the
middle amount of damage although that's
fine yeah and as we drop in for a second
time you'll probably notice that the
frame rate counter in the corner is
absolutely tiny it is why is that cam
well say we're playing a 4k and we I'm
gonna just zip over the other side
because every team over there yes so we
are we're playing at 4k now obviously as
we said earlier this display is 1080p
144 Hertz but and just for a fair test
using the capture gear that we're using
yes we're able to tell the computer to
output at 4k so these are true this is
true 4k performance even the URI are
seen 1080 we are yes but in terms of 4k
were still currently or you were kind of
dotting around the hundred frames per
second mark there year 120 so it seems
to be going between sixty and a hundred
and twenty frames per second wait for 4k
is insane yes oh and to be clear we
still have the settings all absolutely
everything is max settings absolutely so
let's see how it handles some combat
some action almost I really was good at
hitting the wall oh here is he's come to
the Paint Party hey kill monger I don't
think so friends well that's one that
and the frames are still doing strong so
as you run around in 60 frames per
second heads wonderful oh you noticing
it any kind of a difference but 144 well
I mean there is a difference right then
but 60 frames are still real fast and
it's what we're used to playing games at
so it still feels you know nice and
slick especially when I'm running around
but but I think where I really noticed
the difference is then the quick turns
and in the firefight they're like even I
can notice that leading them on it's not
as smooth 144 is smooth as butter it's
so nice for when you're doing your like
your precise aiming and I just think I
just think you can react quicker to two
you know those really intense times like
that firefight just then well I think
one of the special things about playing
on PC especially where the mouse and
keyboard hmm is that you're able to
react that much faster with a flick of
the mouse and you know if you are
getting that level of disorientation in
those quick movements that's gonna
affect your gameplay it is it is and
it's gonna be my excuse if I don't do as
well this around that's for sure but
where's that said you know the computer
although you know we're gonna be seeing
60 the computer is outputting 84 frames
per second yeah consistently at the
moment well I mean it's it's a really
powerful computer despite its size it's
a really really powerful machine hmm now
inside this computer is a micro ATX yes
motherboard so what like what is that is
that just enable it to be smaller tell
me about micro ATX so there are a few
different form factors you can get ITX
ATX and micro ATX right and basically
micro ATX is just a smaller than
standard motherboard and but you are
still able to pack in a lot of power on
a motherboard of that size now what
we've got is and as a cpu we've got an
Intel i7 8700 it's a six core cpu
running at 32 sorry 3.2 gigahertz but it
boosts up to 4.6 and I can guarantee you
mid game it'll be boosted ok then we've
got 16 gig about 16 gigs sorry of hyper
X Ram and obviously the most important
part of any gaming PC
the graphics card yes well the obelisk
gaming PC goes all the way up to an
nvidia geforce RTX 2080 right is their
latest range of cards and is that effect
out we have got the top spec so ec all
the specs to help me play well and win
championships apex and that's what
really matters that's absolutely what
matters is the reason we're friends
sandwiched sandwiched here
alright we're dropping in for another
game because i died you didn't not die
but you've dropped in and you've got the
you know it's really excellent off the
bat so don't even pick it up those every
year I need that back in good stuff oh
I've got the most don't be quit the
hop-up well I've not used this yeah yeah
you've got the sequencing keyboard lit
up to show the buttons you need to press
I do so this is one of the things you
can customize in the omen command center
and yeah I've got the W a s and D in red
and the rest my keys in blue but there's
multiple variations you can use but it's
it's just a nice little thing to help me
find the keys in a moment of high combat
panic which I am want to do when playing
FX legends well you can change the RGB
using the command centre for the PC
itself but the one worth that I have
really changed is the logo on the front
of the PC changes color depending on how
heavily you're using the graphics card
and we were saying that you know we are
getting 75 80 frames per second we are
absolutely hammering this graphics card
as much as possible and so I can
guarantee it is glowing a a juicy bright
red yes front meaning very somewhere
between 98 and 100% I would say but I've
also done some customization said on the
mouse itself so you might notice as I'm
running around here if I run back the
way of chemo jump and then I can slide
by pressing this little button the mouse
button yeah cuz I have customized it for
a better apex player because what's
really important when playing apex is
your movement your real slow when you
got your gun out so you want to bill to
quickly put your gun away and jump and
slide which is what I've been able to do
here just by changing these buttons I'm
not gonna change any of my guns cuz I'm
in a great way here great equipment I
think that's what you know it goes hand
in hand with becoming a better player
any game is being able to have all of
your shortcuts that you need as close as
possible and that way I can just keep my
pinky on shift I don't have to like hit
ctrl or anything to like I mean I can't
that that's what I have to do without it
mm-hmm it's much easy just go on the
mouse easy look at this girl whoops s
the too much too much sliding too much
later too good yes limb all right Thank
You L star and some gifts for you I know
we all start I think I think do it it's
the right thing to do right I think it
is well I died said but my team have
revived me their team nice I'm not going
to say it was definitely from stepping
down 260 thrills at a save that okay can
you say asthma excuse your prerogative
you know was it playing at 144 this is
what we were you know that's what we're
talking about about improving your
skills as a gamer exactly and improving
the reaction times and what's
interesting is that looking at footage
as as slow as 20 frames per second is
gonna look like video yeah but it's as
you step up that you're gonna notice
that buttery smoothness just increase
and increase and increase I definitely
noticed that yeah hundred forty four and
they actually did an experiment with
some fighter pilots who also
unsurprisingly have some of the fastest
reactions going to mid the player picks
legend as they did but besides that they
did an experiment where they flashed up
a single frame in a piece of video for
one two hundred and fiftieth of a second
that's four milliseconds and the fighter
pilots were able to identify that just
four minutes four milliseconds before
one thousand four thousandths of a
second it's very very very fast now when
you're playing at 60 frames per second
you are seeing a new frame every 17
milliseconds roughly okay and when
you're playing at 144 Hertz you're
seeing a new frame at 7 milliseconds
every 7 milliseconds which means you've
got a 10 millisecond difference now if
those fighter pilots are anything to go
by that's gonna be a huge huge
difference and you're definitely going
to notice the difference well cam I'm
afraid that you were eliminated it looks
like the squad is going to try and see
this through to the end watch me I had a
very skillful teammates
there's skill teammates I think that's
the other key thing about improving your
gaming is to make sure that you play
with other good players arguably even
more important than framerate come on
come on guys yes that's how it starts
how you get a championship oh thanks to
me yes and you know what what I find
interesting as well is that you know
it's been really fun
basically being able to play at 4k at
really high frame rates but obviously
playing at 1080p at 144 Hertz oh really
that really made it you notice the
difference I really did I'm not just
saying that because I died that time in
the previous championship yeah I was
still alive at the end but but genuinely
you just you just feels quicker it's
smoother yeah and it's I would rather
play at 1080p one for four personally
mm-hmm then 4k 60 well in terms you know
if science is anything to go by and it
always is in terms of improving your
reaction times becoming a better gamer
and a meta player it's playing at 144
Hertz is gonna give you that opportunity
notice what's awesome and even better as
well if you are the kind of player who
likes to live stream their games where
they don't get carried to the end and
they they make sure they see it through
to the end themselves Thanks you can
actually use streaming software like OBS
encoding using the CPU and you can play
yeah without losing any frames per
second it's just one machine so you can
just on the on the same machine yeah huh
okay so the so the GPU is handling all
the gaming yes the CPU has enough
Headroom left that it can stream
absolutely without losing performance
yes that's crazy yeah so I did a test I
did one at 4k and we were still holding
easily plus 60 frames per second this
was streaming at 1080p 60 so we had to
scale it down but even if you want a
stream at a 1080p 60 but make sure
you're gaming at you know the full 144
you can do that because OBS uses a chunk
of your CPU but there is plenty of CPU
left when you're playing a game like
apex legends so tell us how do you
prefer to play would you rather have
those 144 frames at 1080p which I guess
would be my choice or would you rather
have more resolution and go for that 4k
60
no Emma Collins yes and for more on apex
legends season 2 and for more on the
obelisk gaming desktop PC from omen by
HP head over to GameSpot calm
[Music]